moi je dis non parce que c'est vrai que
la loi de 2004 interdit le port de signe
religieux à l'école mais il y a pas la
liste donc pour moi tant qu'il n'y a pas
de liste là-bas il y a qui est une tenue
qu'elle soit religieuse ou coutumière ou
culturelle et bien mais pas interdite le
voile est interdit d'ailleurs beaucoup
de ces jeunes femmes arrivent voilées
par exemple enlève le voile qui est
interdit et entre en robe dans
l'établissement scolaire donc je suis
contre l'interdiction parce que ce n'est
pas sur la liste et je suis contre le
fait qu'il y a une liste parce que ça va
encore créer des clivages donc
continuons comme ça par le dialogue
Juliette question pour non mais pour moi
il y a absolument aucun débat à voir il
faut absolument justement passer une loi
pour enfin définir la Baya pour ce qu'il
est non pas un simple vêtement comme
certains le prétendent mais un outil de
prosélytisme religieux vous avez
l'islamologue Rémy braque disait que
l'islam n'était pas qu'une religion elle
peut également être un système politique
régie par des lois si vous voulez qui
sont contraires à nos valeurs
occidentales et qui qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être et qui doivent être combattus sur
notre sur notre terre la France est une
terre aujourd'hui de laïcité mais encore
plus important c'est une terre
chrétienne d'origine chrétienne ou les
femmes ne sont pas considérés si vous
voulez comme des objets
dont la vocation et de corrompre le
regard des hommes où elles sont libres
où elles sont respectées donc il faut
bien évidemment interdire la Baya à
travers la loi et je suis désolé mais on
parle toujours de la même religion on
nous le reproche on est tout le temps à
parler de l'islam etc mais pourquoi on
parle toujours d'Islam c'est parce que
c'est la religion aujourd'hui en France
où l'entrisme et le prosélytisme et le
plus le plus ambitieux si vous voulez le
voile le burkini la Baya il y a toujours
quelque chose il y a aucune autre
religion aujourd'hui en France qui crée
ce genre de problème donc oui on va dire
que tu réponds à alors il y a beaucoup
de choses qui ont été dites je connais
ce discours parfaitement parce que je
vous regarde très souvent merci à dire
déjà je vous remercie parce que quand
vous êtes responsable associatif en
banlieue
maghrébins ou noir c'est très difficile
d'avoir accès aux médias en France
c'est signé Nadia aussi d'avoir un
paysage qui correspond à la vraie France
et vous êtes je crois la l'une des
seules émissions on a vraiment de tout
l'équipe de français une très bonne idée
ah ouais donc forcément tu vois
énormément de choses de rejoindre
l'équipe c'est très sympa non mais la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce débat
c'est un faux débat il y avait un sujet
qui était vraiment intéressant juste
auparavant malheureusement sur une
réalité qui est violente c'est le
harcèlement scolaire c'est vrai ça
j'aimerais qu'on passe du temps même à
ce niveau là même si ici on est pas
censé apporter des réponses on essaye de
parents autour de la table je pense qu'à
notre niveau on peut être on peut
comprendre la situation et l'urgence et
la nécessité la nécessité d'avoir un
vrai débat au niveau national sur le
harcèlement parce qu'il y a quand même
des victimes sur cette situation sur le
vêtement bon je suis observateur de du
fait sociétal de comme tous les Français
je suis aussi de confession musulmane
pleinement je suis un français je n'irai
pas jusqu'au terme patriote parce que je
sais ce que ça veut dire notamment par
rapport à l'histoire j'assume le fait
d'être un banlieusard d'aimer la France
avec ses défauts ses qualités comme toi
c'est un faux débat c'est encore un
débat qui est qui est mis en exergue par
des personnes qui aiment faire le buzz
et qui aime taper sur les musulmans et
surtout aussi décaler l'angle de vue
qu'on a aujourd'hui notamment sur la
réforme des retraites sur les
problématiques qui touchent les Français
l'inflation et ses réalités qui sont
violentes donc quand ça finit quand ce
temps médiatique passe on revient au
sujet principal qui est qui est là en
France depuis 20 ans c'est-à-dire les
musulmans après moi j'ai pas de tabou
issu des quartiers populaires je suis
très critique sur les banlieues sur pas
mal de choses qui ne vont pas en
banlieue j'ai fait un appel citoyen
là-dessus notamment sur les violences en
banlieue sur les trafics de drogue les
incivilités moi j'ai pas de débat
par-dessus de ces sujets là mais à un
moment donné quand on parle de ces
sujets vous avez évoqué le fait de
parler des musulmans ou de l'Islam en
général bah c'est bien de nous inviter
pour avoir déjà un avis qui est un peu
plus confort et à partir de là surtout
dans une logique de résoudre des
problèmes pour moi le vêtement c'est pas
un problème parce que demain on trouvera
autre chose à dire sur les musulmans qui
veulent venir en survêtement ou en
casquette à l'école sous prétexte qu'ils
ont musulman donc un moment donné
pour moi c'est pas un problème
religieux pour mettre la bagarre s'il
vous plaît derrière
qui ne sont pas musulmanes qui portent
la Baya dans les États-Unis
n'est pas un marqueur visuel de
l'islamisation en France mais juste un
simple vêtements religieux alors dans ce
cas là excusez-moi
mais je vous laisse
juste mon raisonnement vous dites que la
Baya n'est pas un vêtement religieux et
ensuite vous dites que l'interdire
serait islamophobe donc il faut savoir
est-ce que c'est un vêtement religieux
il y a pas d'islamophobie et il y a pas
de de montage en EHPAD d'un sujet à
viser les musulmans si c'est pas
religieux j'ai pas dit que j'ai pas
parlé d'islamophobie pour l'instant bah
vous avez dit qu'on montait en épingle
un sujet pour provoquer la haine
toujours des mêmes personnes etc et
après vous dites c'est pas un vêtement
religieux
de s'entendre je vous ai dit que c'était
un vêtement qui peut paraître pour
certains un vêtements religieux c'est
pas politique on a souvent et dans les
médias c'est souvent dit que c'est un
islam politique je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire en islam politique ça voudrait
dire que les musulmans et notamment les
citoyens ne peuvent pas
normal vous connaissez la Charrière des
jeunes musulmans considèrent la charia
plus importante que les lois de la
République
pas avec une personne comme moi moi ça
m'intéresse pas ce type de chiffres
juste notamment pour ne pas me laisser
parler et vous répondre parce que là
vous avez mis un peu de confusion à vos
propos donc il faut rester
religieux mais j'ai vu quelques
reportages et les filles qui le portent
à l'école disent elles-mêmes qu'elle le
porte comme une démonstration de l'ordre
de leur foi et de leur croyances et ça
ça me gêne pas du tout qu'on qu'on soit
fier de sa foi au contraire c'est très
bien mais c'est vrai que l'école c'est
un sanctuaire quelque part on est
adolescent et cetera on a tellement de
temps après pour se diviser pour
s'isoler pour rentrer dans des
communitarisme je trouve qu'à l'école ça
doit être un endroit de paix d'union où
il y a pas il y a pas de sens à faire
des distinctions religieuses en fait
moi moi je suis pour l'école en tout cas
je suis pour gommer tous les signes
extérieurs religion richesse etc donc
moi je suis pour l'uniforme pour que
tous les enfants soient au même niveau
que pas de problème ce genre ici aussi
je suis vraiment pas alors que tout le
monde vous veniez tous à poils
c'est pas ce genre de problématique
après moi je trouve que le débat enfin
se va vraiment parce que pour moi c'est
un vêtement religieux c'est même la
définition de la Baya c'est un vêtement
voilà qui fait partie de la religion
musulmane donc à partir du moment
culturel où l'école si je cultural c'est
d'autant plus grave si je me permets pas
des interrompre
ça reste un vêtement culturelle il est
complètement religieusement selon les
pays musulmans parce que les pays
musulmans c'est pas l'islam ou la
communauté musulman n'est pas monobloc
je connais très bien il y a pas de
problème
différent d'accord mais comme le disait
mademoiselle personne ne met des habayas
et ne n'étant pas de confession
musulmane par exemple on va je sais pas
j'ai pas mené d'enquête à ce niveau-là
je trouve qu'apporter sa culture à
l'école c'est pas le mieux
on est obsédé par par cacher le corps de
la femme parce que la femme est en pure
et elle a pour corrompre les hommes donc
c'est d'autant plus grave si on importe
ce genre de culture dans notre pays
radicaux certes musulman mais votre vos
discours est exactement ça veut dire
qu'il y a un entrisme des plus grave
qui est celle de d'une minorité dans la
communauté musulmane qui tiennent ce
genre de propos je vous invite à
rencontrer des musulmans et ils ont
présents
sont menacées donc ça va pas dans le
discours que vous dites il faut pas
globaliser généralisé le voile déjà
c'est pas c'est pas une généralité
toutes les femmes musulmanes et la
majorité des femmes musulmanes ne
portent pas le voir mais le généraliser
un maximum et notamment les chiffres qui
ont été donnés ces derniers jours je
crois que c'est une centaine de cas
qu'est-ce qu'une centaine de cas face
aux millions d'enfants dans deux écoles
170 jeunes
dans deux écoles
si vous allez nier les chiffres par
contre on va pas avoir un débat orange
monsieur c'est pas la tenue des
musulmane c'est la tenue de certaines
musulmanes et minorité et la même
manière c'est pas la tenue enfin moi ça
me choque pas si c'est la tenue des
femmes moi si ce qui me choque c'est
c'est la tenue de d'écolière et vous
vous êtes pas choqué si ce sont des
colliers pour avoir des enfants vous
avez des enfants très tôt nos enfants à
partir de 12-13 ans comment ça vouloir
s'habiller comme ils le veulent je sais
pas si c'est votre cas donc vous pouvez
avoir des musulmans ils veulent
s'habiller avec des rabahia et des
filles qui vont s'habiller avec un jean
ça ça pose pas de problème maintenant si
on commence à avoir ce type de débat
vous imaginez la la la perversité des
personnes qui lancent ce genre de débat
parce que demain on va vous dire il y a
des musulmans qui vont à l'école avec
des des vêtements sportifs qu'ils ont
musulman on va voir un débat là-dessus
donc à un moment donné il faut élever le
débat le vrai sujet et moi j'ai pas
quel autre religion fait de l'emprise
par le vêtement comme ça à l'école
aucune est-ce que les Juifs viennent
avec une kippa est-ce que personne c'est
un moyen de parler
généralités dans les écoles publiques de
la culture si je peux me permettre
Daniel il y a deux choses qui me gêne
soit c'est religieux et ça n'a rien à
faire dans l'école puisqu'elle a la
laïcité soit si c'est pas religieux j'ai
écouté beaucoup aujourd'hui de
d'interview de jeune fille et elle parle
beaucoup de tenue pudique d'impuder ça
veut dire qu'en fait une jeune fille en
pantalon est impudique puisqu'elle mette
ça par pudeur ça ça me gêne aussi
excusez-moi on est au 21e siècle ça nous
gêne il laisse les proviseurs en
première ligne c'est à l'appréciation
des proviseurs pour il a refusé de faire
une vraie liste de signes de choses
interdites ou pas au Sénat le 17
novembre dernier il a dit nous nous
aventurions sur un terrain extrêmement
complexe donc il laisse ça discrétion
des proviseurs et des proviseurs ont
peur je suis désolé il en fait des
cibles et des proviseurs sur le perron
ils disent nous on est tout seul et
c'est nous qui est voilà et ça c'est
scandaleux on aurait peut-être pas
si je peux me permettre ce qui est
compliqué en France et qu'on dit tout et
n'importe quoi notamment sur la laïcité
quand on dit que ce vêtement est un
danger pour la laïcité c'est méconnaître
l'essence de la laïcité aujourd'hui vous
avez des gens qui viennent avec leur
version de la laïcité et notamment pour
taper sur les musulmans donc à un moment
donné moi j'invite tous les Français à
faire un peu d'histoire je suis pas un
spécialiste d'histoire mais quand on
regarde un peu l'origine de la laïcité
quand elle a été imposée en France suite
à la Révolution française et qui a eu un
historique donc j'invite déjà les
Français à ce à s'informer là-dessus
après si on va avoir un débat apaisé
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui franchement avec
comme je vous ai dit le sujet qu'on a eu
juste avant sur le harcèlement sur les
violences à l'école et ce que c'est une
priorité de parler du vêtement de
certaines filles qui ont la volonté
est-ce qu'il y a pas d'autres problèmes
avant à gérer
plus important c'est plus importants qui
se sont menacés de mort quand ils
essayent d'interdire
je pense qu'il y a d'abord une urgence
sur le harcèlement je pense que
ils sont complètement abandonnés
aujourd'hui et non il y a pas d'autre
sujet plus importants
un petit peu leur religion qu'on donne
ce type de comportement cette violence
sous prétexte d'être musulman ou de
vouloir offusqué
de faire respecter la laïcité aux
musulmans on les accuse d'islamophobie
et ils sont menacé de mort pas du tout
mais bien sûr je vous accuserai pas
quelque chose
oui à 82 % non à 17,8%